okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about as the title of the
notebook says biological sequence
processing and often language and we
have both internal folk and some
external experts here so let's start
going through this all right what is
this change listing what what does this
mean it's just a summary of the changes
as a result of this work so where should
we start should we start on this so
should we start on the I mean this is we
talked about this last time right that's
right there's different there's that new
and yes so how should we go through this
should we start at the top here or
should we go through I think start at
the top okay I mean the first one can be
very quick just to get an impression
about the scope okay there's a lot of
bio functions but then our market is
humans who are biological so I suppose
it's not surprising that we have a lot
of bio related things here um that is a
very questionable title I mean a very
questionable name I think okay so you'll
get it we're gonna go through we're
gonna go through all of these is that
correct that's right they're all
represented here okay okay and so these
are these are various underlying so
we've talked about a bunch of this stuff
um yes but you want that one-on-one
meeting maybe one time coherent Li goes
through again from the beginning
good because we didn't make any final
decisions
naming right okay well let's take a look
at this this is interesting
okay so we have genes as entities we
have proteins as entities what about
like animals as entities
for animals as entities those can be
entered in to find bio sequence features
to obtain features of their secret the
sequences that have been discovered from
their genome
ok but so in this diagram they feed into
things here presumably right so the
animals as entities would feed into the
5 find bio sequence features which is
currently an arc from bio sequence DNA
down to by a sequence position segment a
mutation at the bottom there okay so bio
sequence okay so bio sequence
I mean that's that that it's not really
the isn't that's not the right term
amino acid it's really that is protein
DNA is to protein base pair is to amino
acid in a sense so this isn't that's not
an amino acid that's a bio sequence of
amino acids
that's a bio sequence of I mean the the
overarching thing is DNA there and it's
protein there correct maybe not quite
because not any of any three amino as it
don't make you at the body okay
so what would those be called that
sounds like a good name that's what
people hear left that's that's the right
name isn't it I mean yeah um okay
alright okay so then that's interesting
that there's a concept of a so bio
sequence position is the analog of like
a geo position or something that's right
yeah
and it has the analog of sort of a datum
which is the you know which build of the
of the human genome it is and all kinds
of stuff like that
that's right if you click on the plus
there you'll see an assembly okay and so
bio sequence segment is I see we're
hearing clicking typing
patience that's basically a snip but
could it be anything other than a snip
like if it's some kind of big insertion
of a bunch of stuff or a you know a
repeat or something yeah that's right
and not only that snips aren't precise
they can be many different variants and
so this gives more information by
telling which particular variant is
observed okay this looks pretty cool to
me
yeah am i confused or is this wrong
lots of usage here I mean that's a DNA
sequence but this is I I don't know
isn't the analogous thing here peptide I
don't know what I really like the
peptide suggestion I think we should
take that forward okay
I don't quite know why these icons have
to be so monochromatic but that's a very
detailed issue
I don't know why this is what that's
what is a mixed sequence yes this is
kind of one sequence kind of
concatenated after another join in in
some in this case unspecified way when
does that happen
what conjugates of like RNA DNA you'll
get it with the Consulate's sequences as
well although I guess that would have to
do with branching let's do that it can
we need to talk more about how to
specify the different joins and
conventions for that but that's that's
kind of where where things need to be
resolved now yeah so what is unspecified
what does that mean that's when a user
hasn't entered any any type associated
with the bio sequence it's useful for
caching if people forget to they just
forget to type in DNA and one threes
don't return or just genuinely have some
type of bio sequence that we don't yet a
support that some new thing that they
found in their lab and it's our way to
handle that flexibly so wait a minute
but what once you're and we'll get to
the assumption once you've got a bio
sequence in there you know for DNA it's
you know letters representing base pairs
or come you know or uncertain
combinations of those and so on I mean
there's a there's a definite coding of
how we represent the different things
that actually appear in DNA correct
that's right but so for unspecified how
does that I don't understand what that
is it's just like I'm calling it W and
I'm gonna tell you later what that means
or what that's right it's for things
like hedge emoji DNA where before they
had named had a Moche DNA if they wanted
to do some work on it in their lab they
would still be able to represent it as
something unspecified okay embargoing
chemistry there's things like PNA and
peptides things that usually share
sequence but have very different
backbone chemistry
okay so here's a naive chemistry
question for you guys you're talking
about conjugating things okay this is a
super naive question but you've got a
piece of a DNA strand can you'd like
glue a piece of RNA onto the end of it
yeah it's called the conjugate you
absolutely can the linkage chemistry can
be different that's what are you saying
we have to figure out how to sort that
out in mixed sequence like how they are
connected specifically but there's lots
of different reactions that you can
conduct off the end of one strand to
concatenate it to another because why
don't you use those things it does for
glycosylated proteins for instance it
will stick carbohydrates off that I knew
Yeah right but okay fair enough I see I
just have as far as I know I don't think
there's like peptides hanging off of DNA
or RNA that way yeah and like Huxley can
was trouble going to say something but
um yeah I'm familiar with like
oscillation but that being just kind of
just kind of lurking by different
peptides along the sequence rather than
actually filling in gaps in the sequence
so I or working with things I not that
it's not useful for other things but I
wouldn't I wouldn't never have this next
sequence object to work with fair enough
okay let's dig in
what is this broader functional picture
these are some of the extensions that
we've we've thought about for where to
take this work after having covered okay
let's dig in bio sequence creating a
sequence
okay so this first argument cannot be an
entity yes I can okay and and so this
this like funky versions of DNA and so
on those are entities is that correct so
right now we've supplied three based
kinds and we've also supplied a way for
users to extend the listing that's
supported as you'll see subsequently
okay but isn't it the case that there
are like um okay I'm asking what kind of
a thing so there's an entity which I can
put in as the first argument of bio
sequence what is the type of that entity
by a sequence type okay um and but isn't
it my understanding that like you know
critters that live in random
hydrothermal vents or some other weird
sulfur I don't know what they are but
you know that they have different I
don't know exactly what I'm talking
about but I mean they're different they
do have different mappings between their
DNA and then their peptide sequence
their translation is different and we do
support different translation table
entities for that purpose I see but what
about the the I mean between eukaryotes
and prokaryotes obviously there's a
there's a difference in the yeah so the
DNA and the RNA are typically the same
except for in the the transfer RNA can
really differ drastically and that's one
reason why we've gone more with sort of
extended alphabets for transfer RNA so
now this thing here where there's a
multi letter piece in what does that
mean does that mean the T or a or that
means just T concatenated with a so it's
all encanta mated together
so in other words this thing each letter
whatever is represented here is
represented by an individual letter
that's right and so I could as well
represent the sequence as just quotes a
GTT etc etcetera etcetera as one glob is
that correct that's right you could just
string it and it would be what's the
canonical form a strength so it's joined
so this is so this is merely a
convenience that I can put in a list but
it ultimately ends up as a concatenated
string that's right and and we believe
that the world of biology and synthetic
biology and so on is is stable enough
that you know even if we have to use
wild Unicode characters to represent
these things that we're still going to
be able to fit them in character strings
yeah yeah that's the position of a lot
of great existing work that we should be
pretty pretty safe as far as that goes
everybody the bra thing yeah westphall
thing with it's fine for RNA and DNA the
classical thing with amino acids is
usually to use the three letters rather
than one letters that's I've seen but
you can make it work either way thank
well let's talk about that for a second
I mean so the issue is okay the point
that I was making is future proofing
this against the um kind of you know in
in synthetic biology right now people
are still you know very much
piggybacking on existing you know
biochemistry but it's is it I mean I'm
just asking a future question here I
mean can one imagine some sort of
variant of DNA with completely different
base pairs and so on that exists for
sure okay but so how do people letter
those they usually give them names like
x and y and stuff like that and they try
to avoid they're also unfortunately
certain degenerate names like there are
letters that respond to that are meant
to be like any primitive nor any purine
sure so you have to avoid what the
existing okay so let me make a comment
then so to me the bio sequence type
needs to define itself for that so to
speak we're making sense or no I guess
how is that different than each type
defining the alphabet it's over no
that's fine
that's fine I'm saying that the the bio
sequence type one of the properties and
maybe you already have this one of the
properties of the bio sequence type so
when it's you know Martian bacteria or
something you know they will end up with
if it's a Martian bacteria bio sequence
type then the letters one will and we'll
take them still to be letters we'll have
in one of the properties of Martian by
bacterial flow sequence tight is
mapping from those letters to entities
that represent what that sequence
actually is oh absolutely yes
so in other words there should be a
property that is an association that
goes from letters to entities correct
yeah by a sequence type I just added
recently so that each each term goes to
a chemical there's an example of that
below and it also can be extended okay
but I'm suggesting a specific property
of that bio sequence type which says you
know T goes to tyrosine or whatever it
is okay
that's already there okay fine well in
that case I'm unworried about this
scheme because worst case is somebody
has some weird synthetic something or
other
it's a different bio sequence type with
the different alphabets okay let's talk
about in the peptide sequence here um
let's just talk about Brian's comment
about the three letter version versus
the one letter version that may be
specific to my experience too I think
there other people who are used to
seeing it the other way I think it's
different school school okay I usually
work with one letter one letter version
okay so to me I could imagine that this
entity type here defines which one you
whiche which scheme you're going to use
for that for the payload so to speak
were you and say something different how
does the three-letter scheme work
Juliet oh you mean the qur'an's or not
do you mean the code
so do you mean something different no I
mean there's like Matt is Val
there's just three letter
representations oh yeah right which have
combination uppercase lowercase letters
correct yeah usually they and yeah and
there are always three letters too so
you can naively break it I think right
right but I mean so that representation
how do we feel about you know if if what
we ended up with was something that says
you know py ah you know tyr whatever it
is something like this this is this is
great I could just normalize to the one
letter form and then if also add a
peptide free form io sequence type
that's in free form natively and net
conversions between the two and then
people could use whichever they like and
it would get canonicalized appropriately
and everybody could work in whichever
they prefer phone if it's up there you
did return to the step yeah as a string
right now and the string will be
smooshed like this is that correct guys
is that is that how you usually see it
is something like that as a smooshed
string exactly exactly
okay though um okay all right let's move
on here
default Hawtree number of terms so that
is the unread that's the sort of the
blank that's right I'm gonna ask later
about patterns and I don't know whether
this relates to patterns yet it does a
bit now there's a a bio sequence match
cue which handles these I see so this
really is like a blank that's right it's
it's any particular I know what it
stands for I mean I know what the
convention is I'm asking whether for our
purposes when you do things like you
know bio sequence positional bio
sequence cases or something that we are
treating this like a you know like in
regular expressions we have a different
form of you know star or whatever the
the the that this is treated like that
is that correct you know for the
matching functionality there is
something that will expand it into the
expression for matching the fully
specified case I didn't understand that
but we'll come to that on our live
stream someone is asking about circular
DNA that's an is an important case
that's not explicitly represented here
but okay so when you have a circular DNA
how do you what is the framing of the
coordinates for it is there a standard
for that or is it is it I mean just
every circular DNA come with an obvious
start point I'm gonna I'm not kind of
asking travel because I figure he deals
with critters with circular yeah
sometimes usually you'll usually you'll
started at the origin of replication is
I think Convention be by obviously it's
arbitrary but so should we worry for our
bio sequence representation should we
worry should we have for example a
different bio sequence type called
circular RNA or something um I don't
think so
a higher level contract called like a
plasmid or something we you closer
see you then want to say like what
region is coded for what when people do
things like build the plasmid so it
might be a higher level thing rather
than bottom level like this yeah right
but I'm used to just as a simple example
if you look in GenBank and look at
plasmids or bacterial chromosomes they
won't it will just it will still be a
string a Daniel you'll have a somewhat
arbitrary start but it will often be
origin of replication okay okay there's
a couple other edge cases too on the
would represent methylated positions or
in phosphorylation at the end and a
basic site stew is another one that
comes up let's talk about methylation
which I sort of vaguely think I
understand least what it is so you have
to kind of annotate the sequence to show
where there's methylation is that
correct yep what's the standard for how
to do that
don't know if stop it I don't know
either this is the kind of a can of
worms and that if you think of like
human encode the encode project in
addition to methylation there's all
kinds of marks that you put in
functional genomics over like what this
is this a promoter is this an answer or
all of all these things and I'm not
actually sure how those are yeah how
those are canonically work like that
it's another format just one second um
you know one pattern that we have for
this is our annotation rules mechanism
that we've been introducing in lots of
things like audio for example where
there is a you know there's an audio
stream and you don't want to mess with
the audio stream but you want to have
annotations that live that associate
themselves with the audio stream is that
is that similar yeah it's like you need
to know exactly kind of which interval
this thing refers to and it can be
complex intervals like there will be an
enhancer that is not just a contiguous
chunk of DNA it kind of has gaps in it
that were refers to and I took so I
think in the case of annotation rules um
hopefully I'm running a version which
will have this in there um the
you
okay
specify okay so what this is doing is it
says annotation rules and then it's kind
of a free-form thing where it says where
and what so I think that's the kind of
thing we probably wants here
yeah that's meters in a moment yeah you
could use it for both us all three of
those problems methylation
phosphorylation and a basic okay um all
right so then the left-hand side of that
might be one of your sequence position
specifiers although it might be it's a
little weird to put i'm we're going to
come to that because i'm not quite sure
how whether there's a disembodied
position independent of the base
sequence that it's talking about
am i making sense in other words when
you have one of those bio position
things that you had up here does that
have the sequence inside it or does it
what is how does it refer to the
sequence so this is a feature found from
the sequence so this is just the
sequence on say chromosome 10 in this I
know it asking bio sequence position
right I'm asking does this rapper
contain the actual underlying chromosome
10 or does it merely how does it refer
to chromosome 10 because what we're
proposing here if we have annotation
rules and it says okay I've got this
gene that lives on chromosome 10 it's at
this position and that's my main event
but then I'm going to annotate that gene
with annotation rules that refer to this
um but this would be this segment note
the precision don't under Tate the
position you under Tate to sync okay
coordinates line fine fine fine fine
okay fair enough fair enough but doesn't
that segment contain the underlying as
well as the specification of where it is
and what I'm worrying about is if you
sir I'm going to put annotation rules
into the underlying object but the
left-hand side of the annotation rules
is itself a bio sequence segment which
contains the object we're going to get
into trouble
does that make sense I think so because
here notice that our menja sponge right
it's annotation rules are a part number
here that is referring to a piece of the
meander sponge and Ramesh whatever it is
but it is not itself saying menja mesh
in there right but that's kinda a
convention did this annotation Lewis
refers precision itleave also
semantically I am generally yes but that
left hand side can be arbitrary based on
the type of object that appears you know
that it's nested inside
but if if it is a Saudi addressed object
we always can come up there's a
convention so I did know table Rises oh
I know I agree I but I'm saying that the
most natural way to do it is whatever is
inside this bio sequence segment that is
the position specifier we would want a
disembodied position specifier for the
annotation rules whereas we might think
we would want bio sequence segment arrow
whatever but that's not going to work
because the bio sequence segment
actually has the lump of menja sponge so
to speak inside it right it's no
contradiction to say for the bio
sequence that was found there's a
methylation on the that this particular
gene that lives inside the gene sequence
segment so as long as the the two
features are different that you're not
pointing to the same one it's still okay
you can still say we're talking about
the partner yeah I got it
did you understand what I was saying the
problem as long as it like object right
has in it the underlying sequence okay
but yet we are trying to annotate the
underlying sequence so that isn't going
to work but this would have to have is
merely its position information not its
full bio sequence segment and then
you've got a slightly awkward situation
where you want to pull out that that
particular bio sequence segment anyway
let's just put that on the side there
may be an issue with this but in the
first approximation handling sort of
biologies version of annotation rules
with methylation or whatever it is we
should be able to do with annotation
rules I think
see
you
dream from truth-teller saying circular
DNA will be important if you want to
find sub sequences that is a good point
how does that how is that guys who you
know like Trevor you are talking about
the origin of replication what happens
if you want to find a sequence that
spans that or is that never going to
happen because the thing that never
actually be read um it definitely
happens so there you don't want your
your pattern matching to be to kind of
upend at the edges and just do that kind
of do that wrapping in your in your
pattern recognize what what could be a
third argument to something like by a
sequence match cue I don't think that's
a good idea I I personally think that
you should make the bio sequence type be
different for circular DNA ah I think
that will work better because I think
that that way there's so many weird
things that are going to happen with
that like the fact that pattern matching
is different um that you know and it
does it doesn't seem to me like there's
a high cost to having lots of bio
sequence types because I think the well
let me ask you this question is there a
conversion like a critter that has
circular DNA it doesn't like you know in
its larval phase I'm making a joke
because they know these don't you know
on to that level but but you know end up
with a with a non circular DNA or does
that in other words if it's the circuit
of DNA is it like always a circular DNA
or can it be can it have two forms well
the closest thing will be our
mitochondria is circular
whereas our chromosomes remain here
certainly in the lab you can linearize
the plasma that's a normal thing
can I see yeah but you cut it in
different places so then then what we
would do then when you do the cut is we
turn it from you know circular DNA to to
ordinary DNA is that is that right or is
that is that a reasonable way to think
about it that one would change the bio
sequence type from circular to linear
sure although I guess we have to deal
with if you have overhangs not sure how
you do it here other than we haven't
gotten into single or double stranded
what that property looks like
okay well so there's a potential issue
with this circular so again pinning it
on the you know set of issues a circular
DNA bioscience type is is what I'm I'm
predicting we're going to end up with oh
then I have a question about the subject
so if we have such circular DNA is it
only defected with in its own loop its
circular or just an embedding meta
meaning like a different circular DNA's
in different topologies not different
or are they all the same that's a
fascinating biophysical question that I
think can be an answer they can have
things like tension built into them
depending on how they get constructed
and infinitely many types yes I mean I
know I've seen these pictures of knotted
DNA but that is that I mean there was a
big fate you know fad for that stuff a
number of years ago is that can somebody
explain the biology of does DNA get
knotted
uh yes but I don't think it matters for
our purposes like I can't because like
it's important for pack for physical
packing of the material and there's all
kinds of ISO quarters and so forth to
kind of make this work well but I don't
I don't think it I don't think it
matters for our purposes but I yeah
that's like what it what is an ISO cool
so like there are these bundles that the
DNA these bundles the DNA surrounds like
nucleosomes of an inheritable iso course
and the DNA is wrapped around these
nucleosomes that is like serves to kind
of just physically pack things into a
small a small nose and you will you'll
find things like this we're talking
about the markers where genes that are
currently being transcribed the
nucleosomes will have fallen off to
allow the transcription machinery to
attach and then they'll kind of come
back on when you when transcriptions
done and you can read that out and you
can kind of mark what will be bound by
nucleosomes but I'm not sure the actual
kind of nodded yep enough tangled
structure matters if we got into that we
skipped a few steps anyway because
there's secondary structure with single
strand stuff it's much more interesting
with people than this road okay let's
keep going here all right so these
numbers are basically representing
patterns of different lengths that's
right right okay
what is this I wonder whether that
actually makes sense to have the single
that's the single they you know single
amino acid which is otherwise going to
be called peptide um I don't know I
don't know that makes sense what why do
you think that that's a good idea to
have the one argument form it's it it
generalized very well for generating
random instances but I don't know if it
has any real biological utility I see I
see random instances interesting yeah
okay all right fair enough
okay bio sequence convert
that is very weird that is very weird to
me the word unspecified being there I
mean I don't even know why it should
that be automatic or something or what
should that be and is that the one
argument form the thing whether we're
the type drops off rather than the thing
we're the type is there I probably not
probably it's correct out of the one
argument form have the type but this
seems weird to me
so by oh people who are on this call
what is that I mean when would that come
up of having an unspecified we don't
know what this is talking about type
we've got a sequence where we don't know
what the sequence is talking about does
that really come up so that this is
gonna actually be quite common where
yeah you'll have a sequence and then
you'll need you'll need to infer to
guess at what it is and usually it's
quite obvious whether it's going to be
amino acid or or DNA or RNA just by the
letters of that you won't he won't kind
of take it as such when you when you
first enter it into the system well okay
so then then one possibility is bio
sequence automatic come or whatever if
it's plainly obvious it will just go to
whatever it is I mean if you see p/yr or
something like that as a you know if you
see something like that you kind of know
it's a peptide yeah yeah so potentially
inherited in case you work in a certain
context possibly yes either
automatically inherited but I don't like
unspecified as a word it just seems
wrong so I guess this was to the case
where the user just types in a sequence
and then doesn't specify whether it's
DNA what we're saying now the design
should do is if it's off if it's obvious
if there are no conflicts just pick the
right type if it's if it's still if it's
not a type that's found what should it
do sorry I said it again so the user
types in you type ik vond you of Kuti
characters what should happen every time
you say hello world in the in here
yeah what does it do I think it gives a
message I know what else could it do I
mean it could it could I don't think I
don't think having a means like having
an entity type where you've typed in an
entity and the entity isn't one of the
entities in the entity type I think it
just gives an error I mean I think
maintaining something which is a
symbolic entity type it's symbolic by
our sequence types seems like a mistake
especially when we have these things
like circularity that are going to
affect the operation of other functions
but but they could see it to be useful
if we have this mixed once they are
there's a piece of DNA a piece of RNA
and there's something in the middle
which I haven't clearly identified yet
what it is but I know in the lab that is
some kind of marker molecule sitting
there
I think there should be a different form
for that but I look this idea that
you've got letters but I mean this
sounds very weird to me you've got some
letters there but you don't know what
the letters mean is that really a thing
no you mean you know what they mean but
you have not decided on the name of the
type no I understand but but but I think
Trevor was suggesting that there are
random disembodied a G C T Q things
lying around where somebody just says
here's the sequence well what does this
sequence represent well we don't know
yet does that really happen so this
happens to me when I'm blast like I'm
blasting stuff against the general
protein the database and I don't I'm
gonna be lazy and I just want to like
run it in blast and then I'll just drop
the sequences and I don't want to tell
blast - - DNA or - - protein I just want
to run it Evan it's nice it's nice
having blast kind of just figure that
out for me for what it should be I'm
thinking this thing is I see I see well
I mean that I have to say suggests that
the one argument form of bio sequence
could just do something like that
it seems awkward to have to put the
automatic there but maybe not I mean so
the suggestion would be if you type bio
sequence automatic a TTT GC whatever um
that it would then that would turn into
it would canonicalize probably - bio
sequence of DNA etc that right and if it
doesn't know that it isn't a circular
DNA but it's going to have to assume
that and if there I guess there are
multiple types that I could validly be
maybe it doesn't evaluate but gives you
a message telling you what types are
valid and if no types are about what it
also gives you my sister tells you that
yeah and blasts will say assuming
assuming it's protein
and it will just tell you it'll kind of
read that I'll give you a message right
are we going to have a control equals
mechanism where we can do things like
that because
this programmatic form I mean if we say
control equals that sequence I you know
we already have support for some of that
stuff that make sense
probably do it as wsh on our live stream
is asking whether whether they're
looking at this stuff and I'm wondering
whether they should get the faster file
for that DNA I strongly recommend it I
got my whole genome in 2010 and it
entertains me a lot well I don't know I
look at pieces of it for random reasons
at different times and if I know
anything about genomics is because I
play with my own genome um
and yes you can't find all kinds of
stuff from it some of it useful here's a
potential idea for a circular one but
I'm not sure that might make more other
than good we could use something similar
to what we use in literature then
continued attractions where we have
double lists to indicate there periodic
or infinite circular part yes but there
might be more more confusing than
helpful I mean I can think of other
things like continuation characters and
so on and the string it seems like I
mean we're going to an awful lot of
trouble for an awfully we always then
I'm just waiting for the mobius strip to
there are there mobius strip double
stranded creatures and things or is that
a silly concept
probably they don't work the three prime
and five primes don't don't join up like
that you could have a single-stranded
RNA will be a strip I don't know if I
don't know if it's been created fair
enough okay
but that isn't like oh oh the creatures
that um okay
all right so this is
of sub-bio sequences okay
fine with this rather weird thing that
we don't fully understand here that's
right so I mean maybe we need two
different forms we need an automatic
that does the conversion and we need
some kind of bio sequence nun thing we
can just put any random garbage in there
but unfold it right and and it will do
nothing I mean most operations will just
say I don't know what to do about that
but okay
okay that's fine what's that doing is
that Auto flattened that's I it could be
alternatives it's either/or so then it's
a degenerate case oh okay so it's not
Auto flattened and why isn't that then
represented like this
or would that be inconvenient
it's Auto flattening useful or not in
other words if you're splicing in some I
mean I can imagine a case where you want
to splice in some sequence here and
where that sequence you're splicing in
is in a list and where I would want to
just have a list inside a list and have
it Auto flattened but maybe that's just
silly
anybody comment from the biology point
of view might be useful to use the list
to handle branching as opposed to
alternatives disambiguate
okay explain branching
so needless to say these molecules can
branch but what what does that mean I
mean what does that what do you have to
be able to is it always a tree or could
it be an arbitrary graph good question I
think synthetically the way I've seen it
is always as a tree like you a couple of
base that has two positions that can
continue growing and you're from there
you know I have to say it makes me feel
like that a better idea for this would
be to support this together with it and
it's reminds me of net chain to support
something which is essentially a graph
representation here just like we have
net graph um I mean it's a bit weird I
mean this would be and again I don't
know how common all the stuff is but you
know we got a bio sequence here to be
able to put something in here that
represents an arbitrary mean
maybe this is completely crazy but you
know I can imagine okay given a molecule
right a molecule is represented we got
some chemistry folk here right we given
a molecule the molecule is represented
by a graph true
yes yes yeah okay so walk me through if
I wanted to stick a graph in here what
would it look like for from the point of
view of our molecule so let's imagine
I've got a random molecule here um and I
say molecule if I that um why it's
taking time I don't know but anyway okay
so now if I look inside that am I going
to find a graph here I find a big mess
here um I'm gonna find this list of
bonds I say I find implicitly a graph by
virtue of these numbered bonds correct
okay
I am wondering why uh why there's this
weird precision thing here
I feel like looking at but anyway not no
matter here maybe that's just life of
input form um okay so what is the analog
of that for arbitrary I mean I would
assume that these things I mean in a
principle you could represent okay
question could I turn this into a
molecule in other words if I were to
this molecule like representation what
is the correspondence between these two
things
clearly these are you know these are you
know whatever bases or whatever which
are a whole big clumps molecule of atoms
so to speak but what how should I think
about the corresponds between these
forms so between the bio sequence and
the molecule or between the entity in
the molecule between the bio sequence
and the molecule right so so the bio
sequence is a more convenient form for
these large molecules right so you don't
have to keep track of all the atoms in
each I under step on an implicit
attachment point when you talk about
like peptides or DNA it's like which
because it's the most naturally found
one that it connects to and that
actually that matters in carbohydrates
where they naturally branch there are
different attachment points there's
language used to refer to like where
it's being attached on each of those
sort of blocks that are going into the
this sort of meta graph that's larger
than that it's a win mat carbohydrates
is not so where do we represent your
average long carbohydrate thingy is that
represented in molecules that
represented in bio sequence or where no
we were thinking we need something else
what this is and why because it's a
combination of something which has some
kind of graph structure as well as
something which is a linear sequence
structure or what well so I mean they
both have some kind of graph structure
right I mean the bio sequences is a is a
way of writing a graph so the same ring
spokes in the DNA right you have to how
to connect the letter stuff
right so I mean that's a chain graph if
you write it like that like for the bio
sequence there's a relative small number
of elementary building blocks that we
want to use but say for polymers there
is a large number of elementary building
groups I see and in general you could
imagine am I am I right that there's
essentially a graphs worth of you know
the connection of those building blocks
could be an arbitrary graph in a way
that that here we're representing
individual atoms with bonds but we could
be represented in subunits of a
polymeric molecule or something with
with connections in pretend you even
hierarchically right right I mean you
could imagine having a macro molecule
where the the first argument was paired
like atoms or molecules plus attachment
rules right so so yeah so a list of
lists of each one has a molecule and a
list of attachment points and the second
argument you have bonds between the
types that were specified in the first
argument so you're imagining that we
might have a macromolecule wrapper in
addition to the bio sequence map wrapper
yes we had discussed is in two
biochemistry groups in so so if
macromolecule were representing an
arbitrary polymer U which had three
different repeating monomers right so
the first argument could list those
monomers and the amount of the
information needed to add them to an
existing chain and then the second
argument would be how those first those
those repeating units are laid out in
the graph structure how would that
correspond to I mean in the case of okay
so in the case of net graph what we're
doing there is we've got a graph but so
here these are the supply of monomers a
B and C let's say whereas the net graph
and we might use a a thousand times in
the micro molecule right whereas in the
net graph we are
what are we doing well we're referring
let's see what determines the I mean
they're two different things which
monomer are we talking about and what is
its node number in the in the graph if
that makes sense
well anyway I okay let me ask another
question I assume we want to say a bio
sequence with a lowercase with an
uppercase s yes no any comments on this
probably we want it with a capital S
anybody got any thoughts on that seemed
like a trivial question but we're gonna
see this a gazillion times so we might
as well get it right anybody think it
should be with a lowercase s anybody
figured sugar with a capital S okay the
bio sequence as it is written okay least
one opinions
okay good two opinions all right okay
he was in the case there are molecules
on the surface or something if you also
had one be human can you describe do it
one more time this is about molecules in
their physical location like random
molecules that are sitting on a surface
I think that's getting into you know yet
more
yeah right it's so we have to eventually
have to get to solid States right well
and I mean I assume that these
biomolecules also have the feature that
they you know they are in an environment
they're in some aqueous solution or
something and that probably matters to
them but we're not recording that fact
now true not true irrelevant relevant
it's already tool for a single little
molecule right fair enough all right
what's this additional types of bio
sequences okay so you might accustomed
one right but we got okay so one thing
we talked about is the the alphabet
mapping what these things actually mean
that's right if looking at the sequence
cap you'll see an example of that
I would just call that term chemical
association I really think that's overly
fancy I mean I would call it a decision
or something but I mean sequence terms I
mean that that seems very weird I mean
that's like sequence terms as in the sum
of 1 over N squared the sequence terms
of the you know one heart you know
whatever but what are some standard
names for these alphabet okay well
alphabet will be fine by me I mean the
UM sounds great okay okay then this
think caption that is isn't that a
standard Nate standard a named thing in
an entity what's that called isn't that
called label Tony uses label for he maps
it to something else okay so this is so
this is short what is that short name or
something first that's the that's the
picture that they want to but they want
to use ebooks okay so that's a site that
was a time no it's not it's the icon
literally and it would be a picture yeah
correct yeah okay well if you want to be
you don't want always to supply one
that's why we should ally now we're
using what we have fine okay but so the
DNA is is that's a shorthand meaning use
the DNA picture boy that's right okay
what should this be called complement
rules
that makes it reasonable
the two-way rules
it also takes the rules in the single
direction that's just a shorthand I'm
presuming we can take less space as well
yep okay I don't know what the source
means who published this one that should
surely be an external yes identify baby
I think that should record something
different like bibliographic source or
something
sounds good I don't know what
okay what is the sequence cap limit why
is this
this is just examples of two different
kinds of entities so this is this is the
sequence cut all the hatch Emoto action
moji there are two different examples
okay fine okay terrific
okay
okay so then we just need I mean we
could call that alphabet rules
Oh Mike met
um okay
you
okay so this will sit as a bio sequence
of bio sequences is that correct it will
not simplify in any way and the
canonical form so but if I had a DNA
inside it if this said bio sequence of
DNA DNA it would just flatten to a
single DNA is that true statement it's
straight if it doesn't I'll make sure
that it does okay but is that
biologically correct guys in other words
if you splice two DNA's together you
just get a DNA and the splice point is
now relevant which is that true
statement sure yeah okay okay
you
sequence trained fine now why are these
being called chemicals are they
molecules are they something else
they're chemical entities okay all right
fine okay now why is this list not a
list so to speak why is this why is this
being I mean I understand this is one of
these bio sequence of bio sequences but
it's not the right thing to do that
probably is it's the only possible way
or I mean we're going to preserve the
nesting stock draw fair enough but
notice that in the case of the sequence
string case you're not really preserving
the nesting structure well I suppose you
are by having those yeah but wait a
minute know this that this is a tree
this is the linear sequence of pieces am
i confusing something this is only one
level there's only one distinguishing
level here whereas here you could have
multiple levels of nesting
but if the first example would be
mutable deep then this one would be too
I'm confused would be would be lists of
lists yeah okay fine yeah I guess you're
right so the only difference is that the
bottom level of list here is turned into
a flattened string you can join
characters to controi in chemicals right
I want the alternative thing to get rid
of the ambiguity yeah this this one
should be an alternatives right here
yeah so that that's not gonna okay so
fine so we agree that the the pair's as
I know I was um oh my gosh
I lost my place so I'm I'm a little bit
really somehow is this a turn ative I
feel like the alternative is more
head-on rather than a representation of
unknown fact
well it is a pattern and if you did us a
match against it it would it's expecting
my point if you start doing matches
against it
you must go van never up let's look at
that in a matter okay but it's clearly
not gonna work to have a sublist they're
representing alternatives definitely
everything you own in your head oh god
let's try and avoid that if we can okay
yeah I mean this okay categorical
uncertainty is the general category here
right core it and what are we doing for
other forms of categorical uncertainty
like in random choice or something
in random choice we just have a list but
it's an interesting question what I
think we have used alternatives as a
representation of categorical
uncertainty in other cases as well in
outputs not sure not sure I thought we
were thinking about that for some
quantum mechanics thing recently but
then it becomes hard to pedal metric
ended ok let's think about the match
here so you're saying this is an output
and you ask the question does this
string match a string that contains one
of the particular things in it when your
argument is the match is the wrong way
round then exactly humph
this is not apparent alternative is a
pattern construct not a uncertain
uncertainty representation then I would
be more informal the more in favor of
overloading or to work with non
brilliance
of gosh
a
the idea
it would consistent risk colloquial
English that would be very hard to
understand I mean so one of them is the
pattern construct and one of them is the
what would normally be a control flow
concept construct yeah well well okay
we're gonna come back to this okay we've
got my more to cover here I agree
there's an unsolved problem here
um okay we're finally on to section two
here I wonder if it's as long as section
one
okay fine bio sequence features the heck
is that
what this was your original example
couple months ago what is it
find what why is it display round why
isn't it on the why isn't it the other
way around
they're finding in the human this bio
sequence this is very similar to I guess
yeah in this case it should be the other
way around
although then with the snips that's yeah
the ordering does it kind of really
match between the two
hold on first question is in the human I
mean this is kind of an illusion anyway
to say human because you're really
talking about the humans DNA in the you
know the reference human sequence find
okay so this is a kind of complicated
thing alright so here I don't understand
the pseudo I'm sorry I don't understand
the bio sequence position should be a
bio sequence position why does it give
552 after it there's a sequence position
so on in chromosome 16 at this
particular feature that at the you know
167 231 that corresponds to position 552
on the bio sequence that was provided I
know I don't understand this at all I
mean I don't understand I thought what
we were doing here was doing essentially
a sequence position to try to find that
bio sequence in the human genome and
then return the results of that so the
the the position 552 of the given bio
sequence it's found on the human genome
and chromosome 16 a position 167 that
doesn't make any source aying that
complete sequence was not found it was
only the subsequence that starts at I
assume because I mean so find a single
base pair is hardly a right home event
right but the challenge here is that
there are if there are all kinds of
other snips in the sequence then we have
to find a place to hone in on and this
gives us one position or we can say
completely don't understand okay so you
know times when like I matched some
sequence against my genome okay I just
find some some sequence positions on the
genome that match it right which I would
assume would be a bio sequence position
I don't understand this I mean you're
either matching it oh you're not
matching it what am I missing and I
don't understand why why this thing here
I don't understand why you're returning
something which has this in it this
doesn't make any sense to me I mean I
would assume that you find the feature
on the genome and it returns as a bio
sequence position what am I missing
somebody somebody's typing it's very
audible um
you might be right I thought I had
understood it why it was good but but
now I follow your argument ations yeah
okay well let's keep going um so this is
asking
this doesn't make any sense this should
be human snips okay this is a different
way round this is in this bio sequence
where is that snip right right okay
but this bio sequence um it was tied in
might think that's Jeff
okay um
okay so in this case it's fine this snip
in this bio sequence this bio sequence
is anchored to the original human genome
is that correct and repre what is this
what is this thing now we just we don't
know it's just some random sequence okay
so then I don't understand this here I
don't understand this at all because
this snip is anchored to the human
genome this RS designation right so this
does the work of then determining if
that that snip
if the secret matches the sequence of
that region of the genome sees if there
if it aligns and then if it does finds
the position inside the bio sequence
where that snip is found so it does the
work of doing all that alignment and so
forth okay but what if that bio sequence
though it's a thousand base pairs long
and you can see the flanking sequences
on the human genome of that snip and
they match in 900 of the positions okay
what does it do what is it what is it
trying to do that in other words what
matching level will it decide yes I
found it is in that instance it will
fail
because it wouldn't be able to align the
the position that was given to uniquely
only if it finds uniquely along where it
is on the human genome will it then
attempt to find a snip result okay bunch
of people on a live stream are pointing
out the fuzzy matching is one of the
issues that comes up here and for sure I
mean I don't know how that's represented
in this that's right so it's it's this
is a case where it's competitive so your
Givens you have some sequence it may
have some number of snips in it already
so it's not going to align no but I'm
asking the more basic question even that
first example they're finding a
particular bio sequence in the human
genome right right the
case for that is so that bio sequence
might have a pattern variables and it
might have ends and things in it it
might also be the case that oh you know
it's a length mm sequence and oh it's a
really close match for this place but it
doesn't isn't a precise match so how do
we deal with that so the it works but
because it's competitive it's not
comparing it against if it's a perfect
match it's comparing it against all
other available matches so it's slowly
building evidence of okay apartment is
it going to return one of them or is it
going to we like for example I've done
this with jeans of mine that uh that
have you know where there are two very
similar jeans and I try and match I try
and find some random snip by looking at
flanking sequences and it's confused
which you know I'm confused which gene
it's actually you know which thing it's
actually on so what does it do in this
case so either it will overrule one or
the other or it will fail it always this
particular method always has to find the
best match given some considerable
evidence but so it could in principle
there could be two identically weighted
matches in principle right but you're
choosing to return one and for some
reason it's no question in multiple
levels of list with random numbers no no
if it's two and it's close it'll fail
it's only if it can find one distinct
one that oh where the positions are
better compared to some other one won't
we give you a result although that's not
necessarily desirable I mean that may be
what this because that's fair I mean you
know that's it so we might want to
design something which has the
possibility of doing something better
than that but okay so I'm trying to
understand here okay so let's just
understand okay hold on let me just see
what what's happening here so
you
Wow no that's the wrong way around
you're finding it in the human genome
right this is the thing you're looking
for so it's like position in human
genome of this and that should be a
third argument saying what you actually
want to return I think make sense I
think we did that last time and then the
similarity to text cases was pointed out
okay but this is the wrong way around
because it's not in text cases it is in
this
the wrong way around I mean it's it you
know you're confusing yourself because
you've got the snips thing but the snips
thing really just represents the
collection of human snips doesn't it
it's not a designator saying find me
it's saying find me something from the
snips database that matches I mean and
the confusion here is that the snip is
just that one location but it isn't
really it's really it plus a bunch of
data about the flanking sequences isn't
it you know I disagree that the flanking
sequences are used here to make sure
that the snip is actually in discovered
sequence yeah what's what's going on
here is to my mind like as though this
were some other entity class inside of
text cases were saying find me all of
the foods inside of this sentence find
me a but we're not finding all the
sequence we're not finding all the
humans inside that it is true so I think
that the species specification was a
poor choice I think that the jeans case
were refining the human genes inside of
the given sequence makes sense I think
finding the snips inside the sequence
made sense and I went with the human
species specification out of human
deformity but I can see that that is
confusing okay you don't want an entity
for the human genome because what would
it be different than then the human is
the percent okay so hold on second so
what this is this is really confusing
okay this is saying representing this as
the human genome oh boy
but this is again the opposite way
around in text cases right text cases
you give the texture looking in and then
you give what you're looking for right
in this case what you're looking in is
the whole human genome and what you're
looking for is this bio sequence that
you fed in right so it's the wrong way
around and then what you're returning is
a separate issue
let's keep going a little bit here
okay
oh boy oh boy oh boy we have a lot of
stuff to go through here alright so I
this is definitely wrong so fine
confused by this I mean this is you are
choosing to return two things in your
symbolic representation what's to return
b return the feature and the position
here i don't understand why that
sequence is a why that sequence position
isn't the sequence position is the
sequence position a single place yes the
sequence position is a single place for
the purposes of but then I'm totally
confused again because the the then what
you're looking for is where is the
beginning of the sequence so the seating
position is arranged but it's not and
none of these examples is it arranged
yet this bio sequence I can plainly see
cuz it's sitting right there it's a it's
a long sequence sequence length 840 to
the way I guess I interpret it is this
this position corresponds in in the
given bio sequence 550 kudu corresponds
exactly to the DNA sequence position on
this chromosome six is 16 and if you can
it could have been arranged this just
happened to be kind of an anchoring
position that was found that's useful
for well I think it's crazy because I
think that if you're gonna say where is
this bio sequence on the human genome
the answer is it's arranged here right
if you're gonna say where is the start
position or something and I don't even
know if that means anything particularly
with with reverse sequences and things
like this
it just seems wrong whereas this thing
here seems like a better thing to be
returning than just these raw numbers I
mean again I'm I'm I like the bio folk
to opine on whether whether the raw
numbers are useful so I mean what when
I've done this on my own genome I just
you know I often just use raw numbers
but that's just cuz I'm lazy
but it seems like a bad idea to use raw
numbers I mean I think that with the
whole RS thing is all about not using
raw numbers I'm used to raw numbers plus
a reference genome when when I think
about these these matchings which this
is um this seems to to align would have
been very commonly some two steps back
of getting a getting a ranked list of
all of the matches that that come up
okay so bio sequence position should be
like a lat long on the earth relative to
a certain datum it means this thing and
that's what this should be concentrating
on I would have thought it's a bio
sequence position so if you go ahead and
click on the plus
okay but that's just that this is not a
good way to say it I mean it isn't I
don't care what the feature is well this
is saying
okay the first thing this should say in
my opinion is this is a sequence
position in the human genome right
that's that other thing to say then and
it can say it's human genome you know
and then it can have a little gray
version that assembly thirty at six
point six three of those six one three
or whatever it is okay then this is
what feature of the human genome this
happens to correspond to right well
that's actually the first thing to say
is this 5:52 is presumably a coordinate
well to coordinate on the chromosome 16
isn't it
it's the 552 is is it's a coordinate on
the given bio sequence
which maps to that okay that's just
crazy that's just crazy in my view look
if you've got a bio sequence here make
this bio sequence position or maybe it's
a bio sequence segment or something just
say where does that correspond to on the
human genome don't have this hacky thing
I mean people probably done this because
they don't have a way to represent and
you know some symbolic sequence thing
why would we want this why don't just
say this symbolic thing represents the
segment of the human genome that happens
to lie in chromosome 16 it's useful to
know that rather than you know just sort
of randomly saying we don't know where
it is um and then you know say with
respect to chromosome 16 it lies at
these coordinate positions that would be
my expectation that this would just be
167 236 a single thing or or it would be
the span of how that is man okay fine
okay I think that's what it should be
doing I don't know what this is doing I
don't think this is useful this is this
is aligning this number with that
position in this thing just seems
completely backwards and confusing can
it can I ask why is it 550 Q rather than
we're just like just so I can understand
it for the purposes of robustness I
tested this with some snips at the
beginning so it doesn't actually align
to the beginning this is the best
position overall for the entire sequence
I see so you found a canonical snip
that's at 167 231 that it's a labeled
entity and you're it's relative to
that's know right okay so you're saying
so you're saying that position 552 in
this DNA sequence aligns with 167 231 in
this chromosome exactly right
okay but I think that's not what you
should be saying here I think the
primary thing you should be saying is I
mean if this is a match that's worth its
salt so to speak um then how confused by
what that might mean biochemically but
never mind
um the then you should be saying this
sequence lays down on here and maybe you
say it's anchored
to this point as a sort of a footnote
that's how it found that match you know
that somewhere down here below the fold
as more of a detail but that makes sense
yeah Travel does that make sense to you
and yes that does have been commonly
kind of if you drill down in blast or
whatever what's really useful is you get
a little alignment showing kind of your
secede of the sequence that you gave and
kind of how that aligns to the other the
other thing and that alignment will have
positions annotated on it and that just
makes things crystal clear what what
actually happens there fair enough
so it's an iconic thing that maybe gives
some color coding of how good the match
was away from that seed or something hmm
then B what if it's up there you for the
bio secrets position that potentially
gives you a nice graphics exactly yes
okay but what's the difference then
between bio sequence position and bio
sequence segment so I I get its that
position was that you know in reference
to a single position while segment is in
reference to a range it's not yeah but
I'm gonna claim that position doesn't
make any sense
but we don't even need it
I'm open to that idea yeah let's go out
what's going that direction and take it
out at his keep sequence position with
this new compact form yeah okay all
right so then okay so we got a bunch of
details about what we return I claim
that should be a third argument
and I claimed up with a fault
has none of this hair in it it's just
this one object
why this is why this has got features in
it I mean who cares why don't we just
say find bio sequence
and you're just saying fine by a
sequence of you know so then it would be
fine by a sequence and then it's big
small and then features if you want to
and that would return a bio
segment or something and a bio sequence
segment would contain inside it a bio
sequence or a reference it either has
its own bio sequence if it's a de novo
you know a constructed thing or that bio
sequence that's inside it is like the
human genome or something that makes
sense there's a reference feature if
it's available yeah that makes sense
well if there isn't a reference feature
right then you've got an actual then
you've got essentially the reference you
know which is in our world is just a
it's just a copy I mean it isn't really
a copy it's a pointer in memory
somewhere but but um of the original
sequence that's just sitting there okay
and then for example in that case if you
were to try and splice a bio sequence
sequence segment so there's a question
then if you have something which has a
okay here's a question if I've got a bio
sequence segment
of the human genome build 36 and I try
and splice it into build 37
just a meaningless thing right I mean if
I if I'm to say
very common thing is I've got a bio
sequence segment and I've got my
particular personal DNA and I want my
version of that segment how would I get
that
oh it's this segment represents some
range of positions on the genome but I
want to take that cookie-cutter so to
speak and cut out my version of that
from my personal genome how would I do
that
and is that is that a reasonable
operation
biyo focus operation
Centrum person okay so what I'm saying
is um if what comes out here we say find
bio sequence okay and what I'm saying is
I want to find okay so big let me let me
try this for a second okay so let's say
I've noticed that every time there's a
you know a ttttt something-or-other and
some long sequence of somethings
anywhere in the human genome that the
human in question will be bad-tempered
let's say and but then what I do is I
use this
to find out
we're on the human genome does that
sequence in the reference genome where
does that occur and then I want to say
that place where it occurs in the human
genome now on Bob's genome I want to
find out what's at that position
is that a reasonable operation yes yes
definitely and usually that's talked
about in terms of snips it's like the
core thing and then there will be VV
snip and databases of particular snips
that will actually have names to them
that make like that that really easy but
then you'll have some larger kind of
rearrangements and things where you'll
need somewhere I'm kind of bespoke
integrals and so forth right but so it's
okay so I mean this this extractor this
is like a position specifier yeah I mean
maybe the right thing to do is to call
this bio sequence position but have it
often be arranged because then what we
would say is extract from Bob's genome
this bio sequence position which might
be specified by it by one of those RS
snippy things um or it might be
specified by something that was a raw
set of coordinates on build 36 or
something like this mm-hmm that make
sense me okay so this is probably okay
we'll try that for now okay let's keep
going
I haven't a clue what this means I mean
I know what it means you know so so I
get the second example might may help no
I am just I understand what this means I
mean I know what the but the sort of
biologically means but um right so we
get rid of these numbers here because
those they've all been absorbed yep and
these then become biosea this is
reasonable I mean this this is just
saying bio sequence position gets that
probability etc Tara Tara that seems
fine I mean that's that's very similar
to what we would return from the machine
learning system also an association in
that case yes this is identical to okay
fine looks good to me
okay
these were going to change of course
okay but that's the inner tube a bio
sequence position which probably should
be in an association
I wouldn't have a naked thing like that
probably that makes sense given that
we're giving back as dataset to I can
also take the data set yeah why not but
that will have Rangers in it and I mean
and by the way this plus I can't imagine
why you'd canonicalize that with a
capital P make sense yeah okay what is
bio sequence segment and how does it
differ from bio sequence position as
we've now defined it oh I think they'll
become one thing now that we're always
talking ranges that'll all be just
become bio sequence position okay what
about bio sequence mutation this will
also then fold in the bio sequence in
the bio sequence position but otherwise
it's this is you know okay so what this
is representing okay let me understand
what this is representing so this is
saying I want to take I want to find out
how do you get to one of these bio
sequence mutations if you find a snip if
you try and find snips so it's okay so
one thing you can do is to find a small
in a big for example um and yeah by the
way bra
live stream is asking the obviously
reasonable question if I just search for
AAA on the human genome there are
gazillions of them I don't just want to
find one right so and we already do that
I mean for the you know for the case of
non blast type things for the case of
pure literal match we already you know
we have this suffix tree thingy that
does that you know we already have
genome workup for that that's right
right but I don't understand in this
case being able to do fine bio sequence
it's a little confusing of that versus
genome lookup but find bio sequence if I
just ask for AAA I better find a
gazillion bio sequence positions it'll
figure out I'll find a gazillion but by
our sequence positions say we can't
define what I'll do now it'll fail it'll
say we couldn't find enough that's silly
because all of those will have the same
probability it'll be 1 right so that's
just not good enough to have it just
fail but if there are multiple matches
it should return multiple matches and we
need a criterion ok so ok this is now a
biology question again I mean the thing
is returning probabilities of matches
correct but there's a point at which
there really are multiple matches and
the loser probability just you know
there's a point 9 9 at a point 9 7 and
0.94 and then there's a 0.26 what should
we do I would have argue we should
return we should have an acceptance
threshold which is what we do in machine
learning stuff and above that exception
special we should return them that's
that's how glass works where there's an
EVO they have this like pseudo p-value
thing they call a value and then you get
everything kind of above the line I am
depressed that I keep on reinventing
things that already exist well it's
probably a good sign actually so that
seems like the right way to do it is
there a problem with that Jon ok so I
would use probably the acceptance
threshold option that exists in if I'm
not miss remembering it does anybody
here remember what the yeah there we go
acceptance threshold is an option that's
the thing
exactly the same purpose great um
and eventually we'll be able to merge
these things with face never mind we'll
be able to take this comic come a
version for better or worse um okay so
now what is bio sequence mutation none
so by a sequence mutation is
conveniently telling me that I mean this
is the question of you know which snip
means which snip did Bob have so to
speak right right it's which snip fully
specified on what according to what
reference I understand but I mean I'm
asking the question that that returned
so one thing is you're searching for a
small and a big one small you could
search for is a snip which is this kind
of pseudo single position right right
and in a sense what you're gonna get out
see here's a confusing thing when I get
out a bio sequence segment the fact is
there are definite values there
I don't really need this because in a
sense you're not happening to tell me
when I get out that bio sequence DNA
sequence position right you're telling
me it's featured position blah blah blah
blah blah but the fact is at that
position is a T for example right so I
mean the fact that you didn't tell me it
was a T there it's just silly
in my view in other words this bio
sequence segment
I'm also very confused by why the bio
sequence segment is any different from
bio sequence itself but we're going to
get back to that in a second
okay because it seems to me bio sequence
segment is just a nested instance of a
bio sequence because a diet bio sequence
is saying maybe I'm wrong here a bio
sequence I made a difference yeah okay I
may be wrong when does the context in
the presence of an object right I mean a
bio sequence has its base is the world
of all DNA's and then it is a particular
instance of that in this case a bio
sequence position its base so to speak
is a particular bio sequence and this is
a specific location on that bio sequence
correct
I think so okay but that specific
location has multiple attributes it is
because it is relative to that specific
bio sequence it not only has a position
in that bio sequence it has a value in
that bio sequence correct yes okay so
it's not obvious to me that it should be
called bio sequence position it should
be called what it is
maybe it's bio sequence segment again
and what it then returns in it is it's
this sequence of positions and it's this
actual set of values and so you want you
want to get the snip out which snip Bob
has you simply ask what values that
segment has so there's the there's this
the values of the reference and then the
values of the of the bio sequence that
were provided okay now both are gonna be
represented here and so there are
accessors for both but absolutely okay
fine but then then okay then that's a
good thing to have and even in this
thing you might want to you know even
above the fold you might want to be
showing okay so what are the things that
you need to know and what should this
thing be called should it be called a
bio sequence segment or should it be
called something different so okay bio
sequence segment let's assume it's about
is that the best name or is it bio
sequence location or something well
segment is okay okay bio sequence
location segment then it's got the the
um the base bio sequence right that's
the thing that it is relative to and
then it's got you know where this one is
well I mean I'm making this up because
it isn't really the right thing but it's
location coordinates or whatever it is
coordinates then it's content
essentially and then it's reference
content rough
play select and then it's actually got
another thing as well because that base
sequence might be the human genome
beyond coordinates it's also got to say
it's on chromosome 16 and so on right
right now
does it have to if if we're talking
about finding genes does it have to it
probably has to have both sets of
coordinates for if the gene overlaps the
Givens the sequence that was given that
we're talking about kind of two
different sequences sub sequences okay
so let's just understand what this is so
a bio sequence segment the base sequence
there is either an actual sequence that
you derived from your Center from a
sequencing machine or something that
might be the the you know might be the
the the latest bizarre you know
bacterium that
is chocolate or something and but but it
isn't a reference sequence at all it's
just an actual bio sequence that you got
right that's one thing that could be in
that first argument or it could be a
symbolically referenced the human genome
is that correct
am i confused here and then if it's the
symbolically referenced the human genome
you've got to say things like build
numbers and so on there and then you're
saying relative to that base sequence
you are defining a certain segment of in
that base sequence that's right we are
for as it's an output of this fine bio
sequences there is both this the
coordinate content of that was either of
this thing from the lab or the reference
sequence and also the coordinates with
respect to the sequence that we provided
well wait a second okay let's go over
this again okay let's say that the thing
we're searching for is a gene I don't
understand why that gene doesn't
essentially read across a particular
part of the base sequence
so the challenge is that week somebody
gave us an arbitrary bio sequence that
we found and we now need to say given
that we know that we found this gene how
does that overlap how does that refer to
how does the gene refer to the sequence
that we gave no this is muddled look
look either okay
okay one thing you might do is say I've
got the sequence a GB you know a GT T
whatever it is right I want to run that
sequence against every organism in my
collection and it's gonna come back with
a bunch of bio sequence segments correct
with I mean and so the way that would
look is you'd map you know what we
calling it find bio what will we calling
that thing
find bio sequence I think which is
itself totally confusing because we're
not finding a bio sequence we're finding
a bio sequence segment and for finding
anything well I don't think it's right I
don't think this is right but anyway
let's assume we did that okay
so then we say map that over and then
what's here is a bio sequence right pure
bio sequence no reference no I mean it's
the only it's just saying it's DNA it's
this thing here right okay so now I'm
mapping this over you know let's say you
know Pig goat antelope okay and then
what I
back to get back is presumably is bio
sequence segments
in which this says is the pig reference
sequence
referred to and I think it needs to be
decorated because you need to say well
it somewhere you need to tell it that I
want build 17 of the pig reference
sequence or something um and this if I'm
mapping it over the pig entity here
that's not telling it that okay
so then here then it's got to go through
all these all this jazz of in relative
to the pig reference sequence where is
the sequence that I gave you right
coordinates whatever it is whatever
right now that's what I think that that
BIOS sequence segment is now if somebody
then says there's a resolver for that
that says what is the sequence from that
sequence string let's say or
alternatively what is the bio sequence
from that because the bio sequence which
in this case was rather trivial because
we just looked for it but if that bio
sequence had a pattern in it it wouldn't
be quite so trivial to say which actual
one did we find
you see what I'm saying
yes so what am I missing here so let's
imagine what some other case is here so
we say the other another case you're
talking about is find bio sequence
segment of in the human in the pit well
we've already got in the pig find this
so then another case would be find it in
this bio sequence in my custom bio
sequence which might be Bob's DNA or my
DNA for that matter
um SW DNA here
okay so we've got this custom sequence
here and I'm gonna and then which is uh
and then we want to find the position so
we might want to find the position of
the snip with an entity snip entity here
you
and then some random RS whatever it is
right here
am i making sense and then what we want
to get back there is what are the
particular coordinates on my DNA that
correspond to that snip and what is the
actual bio sequence that I have at that
snip right and that actual bio sequences
I've got to see if I was smarter I would
have a tea or something that makes sense
this is good so far the case now I'm
worried about is that where the features
are about the same size where you're
working you have a bio sequence and
you're looking for if a particular gene
is inside of it or overlaps with it or
something like that
okay well let's look at that okay so
what you've got there is you've got
something where you are saying that you
are prepared to allow I mean if we were
doing string matching your string match
would simply fail if if one end of the
string wasn't Matt you know if the
string only matched you get what I'm
saying yes me half the string matched it
would simply fail right what you're
asking for is a match where you know
your reference ref sequence and your you
know sequence e of searching for where
the sequence you're searching for is not
contained in the reference sequence
correct that's right it might it might
not it might just overlap okay
okay so bio folk are those two things
considered the same in biology sequences
contained in the reference sequence or
sequence overlaps the reference sequence
I think so okay a small note here that
internally for what we're doing we
generally work with FASTA files and VCF
files FASTA being just a sequence which
would be I guess the bio sequence in the
states and also work with variant call
file which is then basically you need to
you always need to be working with a
reference and a VCF and a Visia tells
you how you need to transform the
reference to get to why'd you what you
have and that is not to be the case
you're doing much more but that's that's
kind of what internally we found you
okay so in other words that yes again
the concepts that we're inventing here
have already been invented
that is the VCF thing as an anchored the
faster file right like you know I got my
mitochondria in first years and years
ago and it just came as a blimp here's a
bunch of you know his a sequence um and
that was all the FASTA file really
hadn't apart from a little bit of bran
and metadata um whereas the VCF thing
you're saying it's an anchored thing
relative to a reference sequence that
you got your sequence you know your
genome sequence today they could hand
you back a rather than three billion
base pair of FASTA they could hand you
back a roughly hundred thousand line VCF
that would tell you for each of these
snips what do you have relative to the
reference where you know it's longer
than that right I mean don't you have
like 700,000 de novo snips yeah okay
sorry
never better than I do 700 well that's
the de novo snips that's not that's the
snips that you have that have never been
seen in a database the number of snips
you have relative yeah anyway no matter
but it's a longer thing but but I get
the point it's much shorter than the six
billion mm-hmm the okay okay so now
you've got this case of the overlapping
thing well I don't really think that's a
huge problem I mean you basically are
just there's some coordinate thing you
have to specify here and you know I
don't know it's some footwork that we're
not going to be able to do here that
we'll say that but I see yeah yeah I
think it's that I understand right but I
don't really
these names at all no concept is what
son know that the names are now no
longer correspond to what we've
discussed master okay
okay that's wsh on our live stream is
pointing out about analogies to temporal
data instead of common x segments have
ya so what happens in the case of
multiple reads you know the output from
a sequencer does not contain just a
single sequence value at every position
oh yeah yeah so there's this hole and we
problem base variant calling problem
that you'd have to go through from her
kind of pile of raw greens to this
consensus genome that you're dealing
with here right but I mean if we wanted
to represent the raw reads I guess those
those are usually compressed into saying
it's a C or a G or something rather than
ever showing you the whole stack um okay
the yeah the VCF will work pretty after
you've done assembly but work is the
sort of thing that people use for this
we represent of your raw reads 40 out of
your hundred at this position are
calling it as this as this thing so
that's again something that we're not
able to represent here which we would
like to be able to represent the
different probabilities for each I mean
one could imagine in the bio sequence we
could imagine something like this where
we have you know a a G C T and then we
could say something like um a 0.6 G
point for at that position that wouldn't
does not be what I was you know I was
more thinking like to be we have eights
goes to sink if it's path of closet and
rope let's let's
a separatist tree I think this is
probably the better way to do this
because this will be better for you know
by the time you get to amino acids and
things where they're where it's quite a
sparse story but the question now is
yeah so a question from a live stream is
do you really have to represent so as
you say individual humans differ only by
millions of base pairs not you don't
have to specify all the billions and
that's like saying so you know if you're
throwing around genomes if you we don't
want to have to have everybody's genome
completely represented in the system so
how do we deal with that can we have a
bio sequence that is a relative bio
sequence so to speak
you
in other words right now you have a type
here but you could imagine something
which is a bio sequence in which there's
a base bio sequence here in which there
are dips here and that will be analogous
to the VCF file yeah that's good yeah
and then as far as you know as far as
manipulating these things are concerned
we would have to make it so doesn't make
a difference which one you have but this
would be you know given that you're
dealing with a human you know you might
as well represent it this way if you're
dealing with an unknown martian
bacterium then you don't have a choice
you just have to represent the wrong
thing
but now in this model where you've got
diffs relative to a base this is making
bio sequence segments look an awful lot
like bio sequence where the only
difference is that you're saying if it's
a custom base you might say the default
for bio sequences it's the whole base if
you understand what I'm saying
the whole base sequence but an
alternative is it's just this
coordinates position in addition to
diffs you can be doing that as a
selector so you say it's just this
coordinate position relative to this
base sequence right but if you're simply
typing it in as bio sequence of Ag CT
whatever it is then I mean I don't
completely understand the base space of
having DNA vs. and I could even imagine
that the real correct form is something
more like bio sequence of you know
something like DNA arrow base diffs I
mean although you know this could just
be a single entity because you know it
might just be the human genome which we
know is DNA
I think I just think there may be a
useful factoring of the base type of
thing you're dealing with relative to
the actual okay so so that then instead
of bio sequence of DNA comma yeah I
don't know it might be useful look it
may be useful but then you've got these
mixed things I don't know I'm not sure
not sure how to do that whether you want
instead by a sequence of DNA the base
sequence and then the diffs here and
that's the only data structure you're
dealing with and those diffs could mean
just I just want this part or they could
mean here are some changes relative to
the base
that make sense and then the accessors
would so you know there's clearly an
access or which would which would turn
this into the pure sequence string and
that would resolve both the the part you
know extraction and the diffs
right and the diffs presumably I would
assume would be well I would assume that
they're in Dell I don't really know how
that works and I don't know how you
store so in VCF presumably is it storing
in Dells substitutions and in Dells I I
don't know it should it sure but that's
not a trivial thing because and a
deletion at the beginning is going to
shift everything down so there's
probably a much smarter way to store
these things then it involves you know
you don't want to have to in other words
you have to do essentially a a prefix
type thing where you're you're going
through it's like a fold list e type
thing or you starting at the beginning
and you're saying oh I've seen this
number of deletions therefore my
coordinates are off by this amount at
this point see what I'm saying so I mean
it would be rather inconvenient if you
say oh this thing that has these diffs
now I want position 100,000 whoops I
have to go resolve the diffs before I
know where position 100,000 is there's
got to be a better data structure than
that for it um where you kind of yeah
to be a data structure in which you you
basically are storing I don't know I
don't know anyway okay um okay
we are beginning to run out of time here
and oh my gosh look at this
whoof
well okay that's fairly straightforward
good that one was easy so again here see
this is a typical example where you're
not really where you really need this
base sequence okay you need to say what
the heck are you can ask for here I mean
so so here you really need to have said
I want because I mean I couldn't the
base pair sequence for this how do I
know that I want the the amino acid
sequence did you give it you give it a
certain type of a I'm confused
there's a big unity
um hold on one second
this is the VFC spec um
you
it's kind of ugly but it seems to get
the job done and it definitely goes new
popular well okay so and maybe there's
good you know tools for handling sort of
this question of I want position 100,000
you know stack up all the in Dells
before me so to speak um but okay back
back to myoglobin and what it actually
is um in other words first of all I
assume that that is human myoglobin
that's right okay so then the correct
thing for this to return for bio
sequence myoglobin I don't know what
it's correct thing to return this I mean
I think you have to say you you know it
might have a default but you know I
think you'd have to say bio sequence and
this is again this actually makes the
case for the thing um the um you know so
here we would say DNA and then entity
I don't know I think I I'm beginning I
think these should be packaged somehow
I'm not quite sure how whether it's like
that or a pair or something but if you
like this concrete example it's not so
much different of molecule of chemical
yes it is because a molecule consists of
a bunch of atoms and bonds that is the
only thing it can consist of whereas
here this protein well okay okay you're
saying this protein is an amino acid
sequence so don't ask about the DNA
sequence convert to get to the deal is
it because like you could argue if you
argue your way then I would argue the
chemical is not a molecule but it is a
money many-body system of infinitely
many yeah right right okay so here this
would be bio sequence of and this would
then be a peptide and then it would have
a sequence whatever that sequence is you
know whatever it is um
fair enough fuse aboard Eid
sorry possibly if you start with the
port in entity if you start with another
entity not
like your left hands I distrust 14 and
did not trust any entity Yaya right
right and if the if the entity is a gene
then the this right hand side encodes
the base here is human genome DNA and
then the the diffs in quotes give that
particular location for that particular
gene on the human genome
that's right
I II III and we'll do that for the whole
of my DNA
why is it called sequence molecule I
think it should be called bio sequence
molecule if it's called anything why
isn't just molecule of that thing why
isn't it molecule a bio sequence
so I'm stealing this functionality from
the chemistry folks there Jason would
have to weigh in here let's see so
sequence molecule is an internal I mean
at the moment it's in the chemistry just
this molecule a bio sequence gives a
molecule yeah it's like okay that was
simple yeah so I mean in internally I
will ask for the the sequence and then
feed it to the function sequence
molecule that we've I don't care what
you're doing totally you can feed it to
you know pet function that but I mean
from probably view the user this would
then return a molecule this is then
converting it to molecule representation
now a more interesting question is bio
sequence of molecules the round trip
right because it wouldn't actually have
to be a sequence of molecules not I mean
you'd have to have a list actually do to
make the cut side right it will write
enemy important so we could cheat a
little bit in that and when we when we
make a molecule from a bio sequence we
may have met it was amazing yeah yeah so
I mean just make it one of the
properties in the meta information
storing the sequence so that so that we
don't have to recognize the sequence
you read an instance I don't see a
problem with that
that is a grotesque
return value in my view I mean I've
never liked that I mean I invented it
but it and I've used it a gazillion
times before well it's better you know
I've used it on my own genome for
example and I have to say it's not
totally terrible I mean it's you know if
I want to find where do I have snips you
know I got this big gene it's a mega
base long and I want to find my snips
there I can at least see very quickly
where do I have variants
you
but they're the the inner list head I
don't like well I understand it's quite
convenient though I mean am I in my
experience using it it is not completely
grotesque I don't know I I have not come
up with a better way to do it you don't
think they trust a rule in the inner one
would read easier
ah yeah that might be easier that might
be better either way though it's still a
weird thing to break up what is
ultimately just a string put a little
list and have weird annotations I mean
it reminds me of what we're doing with
things like text structure um
what is the point here so for dents
alignments this is something that
Trevor's are used where we you have kind
of each sequence is maintained and then
dashes are added and so you have the
original tracks and can work with the
original tracks for further analysis I
didn't understand a little bit but I
should have another question in this
business about acceptance threshold and
so and clearly the match is that you've
got to be able to do for the whatever
the fine bio sequence thing is okay has
got to include ends in the thing being
found and the thing both the big and the
small could contain ends yes so yes so
this is a weird case of pattern matching
because in ordinary pattern matching
it's like match this pattern which has
banks in it to this thing which is
literals
whereas what you're doing here is you're
matching patterns to patterns so in
other words if I say if I for example
have nnnnn and I'm matching n n to n and
n and n then clearly that matches in
many different places
and happily says it's rather you know
rather degenerate but it's gonna say
there are matches it's nn with lots of
alignments but that's okay I mean I'm
just pointing out something that should
work right you should and I'm not
confused right I mean you should be able
to have both unknown it could be
anything in both the big evenly even the
reference genome as ends in it I feel
great yep um so fair enough okay right
similarities scoring
great
Wow Wow okay that's a you know we can
don't tell me we can do we can do string
replace and it'll do a CRISPR for us
something like if you if you know if you
like this you must accept it again seed
oh I can imagine that doesn't like I
mean and I also wonder about a rule like
that because I worry that there may be
some biology specific transformations
that are not allowed I mean it's a nice
shorthand but I you know I mean I'm not
a big fan of it though I understand its
usefulness but I'm trying to form a
language point of you know the biggest
why you think it should be bio sequence
replaced by of sequence reverse etcetera
yeah I think that's some safer thing to
do significantly safer it can be
cognitively similar to the string
operations but I mean and by the time
you got freaking circular DNA's and
things those are that's coming we don't
have circular strings and also we have a
lot of options to string replace which
probably don't apply here and just yeah
this is cool I'm just as an example that
this would come in a lot with his
restriction enzymes so often you want to
know where restriction enzymes cut and
those will have certain particular
motifs that they'll cut which would then
probably be like ATG in GE for example
and the N actually doesn't matter and
that in that kind I see right so it's
got to be bio sequence replace etc I
mean just think like ignore case what
does that do for a bio sequence who
knows it just doesn't make any sense so
make them bio sequence whatever things I
think now what is this bio sequence
string processing no no I don't like
that it's just let's not think of them
as a string so this just basically to
not have too many own words a cheap vay
it follows basically matrix function
like we don't have all our clear handle
special functions repeated for metals
but we cannot use them because they
scared of all this so that's why wave
matrix function
yeah that's that this is different
because I mean the string operations
that you might want to do oh gosh string
take they're exactly all that you might
want to take
well if I was doing it I wouldn't have
hi you can of course map it at precision
too but that's ugly when I took up a
comments on livestream one is visualizer
wouldn't a visualizer be better than
this wouldn't a blob effectively that is
a visualizer for this be better and I
agree or blah blah but maybe with
sliders and things that you could go and
look through the sequence or zoom in and
things and I agree that that would be a
nice thing to provide suggesting that
there's a sequence alignment object or
something that comes out and we could we
could actually you know because sequence
alignment is a useful function for
things in general used for all kinds
I've used it for all kinds of things
that have nothing biological about them
we could imagine a bio sequence
alignment which is specifically for bio
sequences and which has special features
like coming out with a blob
I think that would be useful now okay
we're gonna need to talk some more about
the string stuff this is kind of
grotesque I mean I I feel like if you
just wanted his string operations
extract the bio you know extract this
sequence string do the operations and if
you want to stuff it back in again
because I don't think I predict that you
know there'll be a few operations that
really make sense and a lot of others
that really don't and I mean the
question about you know I don't think we
should really distinguish
complementation from reversal for
example and having one be string reverse
we don't have a string complement
because we don't say you know B goes to
Y C goes to X type thing or something
crazy like that right so complement is
very much a biological thing for us so
you know and again there may be well
yeah and reversal I don't even know what
reversal well yeah okay um
well some on a live stream just
suggested the exact same thing I suggest
about transforming to string just string
um s WS H is wondering it from the
distant future the way a high-level
language for expressing genes their
interactions instead of as they put it
this obscure base code programming for
life yeah many of us have been wondering
about that for a long time
actually I a question for our bio folk a
just out of curiosity has anybody made
progress on that
of something higher level for expressing
what's going on
I don't think so fair enough it's
assembly language the um the um like
it's just layers and layers of in
through encode of like nucleus homes and
methylation and all of the things and so
it's just a big dictionary that's
getting getting bigger and bigger
without without proper rules right and
we don't know the programming primitives
for life really I mean we basically
don't know beyond very straightforward
things I mean we don't know you know the
analog of the functional programming
primitives we barely know I mean that is
what is the higher level primitives of
you know this restriction enzyme acts on
this thing and cuts and splices and does
this and that I guess we know some of
those operations
but is there a higher-level notion of
you know this is the these are the
functional programming primitives that
represent interesting things that happen
in living systems
the problem is there's no guaranteed
hierarchy or modularity or anything -
because it's just what evolution comes
up with we try to put abstractions on an
after-the-fact but there's gonna be
plenty of rule-breaking things that
don't fit nicely into a box like that
fair enough
even as probabilistic kind of
programming constant I mean you know
this up regulates that or something I
don't know whether that's up but that's
not really a programming yeah okay fair
enough
oh boy
all right we need to discuss this some
more I don't know what the right thing
to do is here
okay I think we're running out of juice
let us there just rework the segment Inc
okay um this looks fairly
straightforward this one I think is
going to be fairly straightforward
he says famous last words I mean
transcriptions and and translations and
complementing z' and so on seem fairly
straightforward I I would think that in
addition to this you might want a an
access over here that says reverse
complement string and so on they don't
cost anything indeed what's the plan to
approach things like secondary structure
and that kind of thing and that's that's
the first thing in the in this kind of
broader functional picture work
extensions so yeah what would you like
it to be I mean in that is that it's
you're trying to say this this RNA
folded in this way or something is that
what you know in addition to saying this
is its sequence yeah exactly
and I'm you know that applies even a
protein folding in coronary structure
and all that good stuff is possible and
ripe for representations here well so I
mean the way we do that in molecule is
we have this atom coordinates concept
yeah so similar to like you can convert
a sequence to a molecule you'll be able
to convert secondary sequence to
structure in terms of a tonic position
and that sort of thing but you want
higher-level
you want to be able to say like this is
an alpha helix is a sheep you want to be
able to say this is what like an RNA
fold looks like right in terms of Watson
Crick pairing instead of actual atomic
positions and all that you have an MD
simulation these are the water in atoms
this is like how your protein is
flopping yeah I mean there's things in
will do like folding of RNA is just a
function that takes RNA in and spits out
a bunch of secondary structure it's a
super useful function they get rise
which can actually be done for RNA as
opposed to exactly exactly it's not
nearly as hard a problem when you're
just dealing with what's a quick pairing
instead of tertiary interactions but so
in our case then what I would imagine is
bio sequence I don't understand why bio
sequence like molecule I mean molecule
has a logical graph theoretic structure
independent of its spatial these are the
positions of the atoms structure and I
don't understand why we wouldn't do the
exact same thing for bio sequence it has
a logical chain structure but then it
could have coordinate positions that are
annotated into it is that an obviously
wrong thing to do and then then you can
ask questions I mean these questions
which we don't get to ask on a molecule
okay so let me ask this question okay
I've got a molecule I want to know I got
this big molecule and I want to know
will this random
you know molecular proboscis fit in my
molecule anywhere how can I answer that
with our our molecules setup
oh it's it is a computational geometry
try question is there a hole in my if
I've got some and this is docking yeah
but you do want before you get straight
to that you do want some kind of modular
higher level representation of secondary
structure before heading down to atomic
position because it's still referred to
and like you'll have things that you
want to do homology for predicting you
machine learning to say this hidden
Markov model says it's probably an alpha
helix here versus a beta sheet okay so
kind of classical can't bio problems
that you're gonna want to tackle but so
that's similar to the annotation rules
thing where you say this is methylated
in this area this is an alpha helix in
this area
isn't it you could do it that way I mean
that's basically how we do folded RNA
DNA this kind of a secondary listed the
of the bond pairs what goes to what in
order to be able to draw a structure and
say this sort of looks like in in you
know TV okay fair enough so I mean
you're saying we should be able to use
annotation rules to annotate you know
like like you know I don't know whether
there's alpha helixes and beta sheets
and things and I'm sure there's
I mean I've even seen these sort of
periodic tables of weird weird repeated
structures that exist in proteins so you
could say and I'm going to annotate this
is a your head and shoulders
configuration inside my protein or
something isn't that right I mean that
that I might want to annotate it with
other other sort of facts you're saying
that go that are less specific than its
this atom position
it's a she could in theory be used for
anything right but whether you make it
you elevate it to a higher level of so
there is a construct for it might be
worthy consideration because it agree
but I think with annotations we have
this convention that you can have you
know there are standardized keys for a
an annotation given as an association I
think that's a possible approach to that
which is both extensible you know as
people choose to do different kinds of
tagging and can handle knowin kinds of
tagging in special ways um where the
question here about missing inside these
things and yes we should deal with that
we should deal with having missing turn
into ends in other words the symbolic
missing should turn into an N and in
certain cases we might want as matter of
fact we might want to get it just like
we say sequence string we might want a
sequence list as well that has things
like that in it possibly
that make sense
brian is asking how to similarity
scoring treat insertions deletions
substitutions that's a whole elaborate
story
and
um
yeah it's it's some SWS h's is
commenting about the the hierarchical
nature of you know it's all physics
eventually you know the terrible thing
in in my physics project which I'll be
starting to talk about hopefully in a
few weeks is you know you talk about the
need for a higher level programming
languages for things this is a extreme
version of that where where it's just
built out of out of unbelievably
abstract things and the question of how
you think about it in terms of something
that's that one can seriously discuss so
to speak you know like biology has never
solved that problem I hope we'll be able
to solve that problem for fundamental
physics but we'll see um
ah yeah oh saying I the figuring out the
shape of protein from amino acid
sequence is not quite solved I think
that would be a fair statement although
I don't know whether as you know Trevor
probably knows Mohammed Al Qureshi whose
former employee of ours have you guys
have interacted with Muhammad in this in
these conversations yes yes I've had the
pleasure to talk with Muhammad about
this and also know what that Trevor has
dropped off the column fortunately oh
the okay um well anyway so so Muhammad
claims that he is really made great
progress using machine learning and
other things and this protein structure
thing which is a long-running difficult
problem but okay so he got lots of stuff
here - oh boy lots and lots of stuff to
talk about
okay sounds good
I think we didn't completely solve so we
got one bio sequence thing and we
probably got this find bio sequence and
bio sequence and we still I feel like
after native yes but there's a bunch
Basel is your outside of our sequence
here right yeah right I mean it's the
categorical alternative so to speak um
but even other ones for every term there
you for certain entity where you think
you don't know quite what it is but we
have narrowed it down to a couple
alternative well I mean the obvious name
that we could use no I don't know
there's either it's a bit too two-sided
though anyway yes it's a little bit -
okay
the UM all right well very interesting
stuff this is great I mean there's a
wonderful fascinating thing and also to
our meetings yeah we we I think we can
assume like it'll be that I mean it's
big area right
how long did it take us to do chemistry
how many how many hours of meetings did
take us to do the design of chemistry
I'm guessing - I would say 10 I not more
I think was more than 20 I think it's
more like 20 um which is modest
honestly it's okay these are big areas
um it's alright well look forward to it
thanks everybody
that sounds great thank you folks thanks
a lot everybody see you later